- Let's map out
a generic low-cost
leadership business model.
Every business will have
a different business model
which is unique to their situation.
For the purpose of this example,
we'll over-simplify things.
As we know, a low-cost leadership strategy
makes the trade-off
between margins and volumes
where the firm will lower prices,
accept lower margins, in order to generate
higher levels of overall volume.
Done well, this will give the
firm superior performance.
How would this look like
in a business model?
It can begin anywhere,
but the idea of a business model
is to show how all the parts work together
to create a virtuous cycle.
Let's assume that the firm
intentionally charges lower prices.
Effectively, the firm is re-investing
potential profits in lower prices.
Those lower prices generate higher volumes
because customers are likely to buy more
if prices are lower.
The increased volume gives
the firm an opportunity
to achieve lower costs
through better scale,
or larger purchasing discounts,
or better economies of scope.
In turn, these lower costs
create increased margins
which can be re-invested.
The margins can be
re-invested in more marketing,
which should drive increased volumes,
which in turn will create better scale
and scope for the firm,
lowering its costs even further.
With further-improved margins,
the firm could invest in more R&D.
That R&D could lead to new
and better-quality products
which should show up in
turn in increased volumes,
which should improve the scale and scope
of operations even further.
Or the profits could be invested in R&D
to produce process innovations,
which could lead
to more efficient
manufacturing operations.
With every iteration
of the virtuous cycle,
low price and higher volumes join together
to generate higher revenues,
which generate higher firm margins.
What you see in the diagram
are the coherent causal relationships
between the different activities in a firm
that is pursuing a low-cost
leadership business model.
Done well, this business model
should become a
self-reinforcing virtuous cycle.
Over time, firms with
coherent virtuous cycles
can pull away from less efficient
and less coherent rivals.